- [Interviewer] All right, Amisha.
- Yes
- [Interviewer] Amisha,
where'd you grow up?
Where are you from originally?
- I'm originally from Belize,
moved out here to the
States started in Atkinson
and then moved to Long Beach
with my mom and my dad.
They were married, he
was in and out of prison,
so then she turned out to have parties
and drinking and smoking and fighting,
and me, my sister and my brother
all have different fathers.
I would say I'm the black sheep,
because I was always
the one getting beat on,
pulled by my hair, hit
with arms, broomsticks,
having carpet burns,
black eyes and that all
started with my mother.
I had to take care of my little sister
and my little brother.
At six years old I learned how to cook,
I learned how to change diapers,
I learned how to potty train a boy,
because my mom was never home.
- [Interviewer] Where was mom?
- Running the streets,
probably prostituting.
I know she had her head busted one time
and she came home with
a shower cap on her head
and had blood all in it.
I don't know if the guy
was trying to rape her
or rob her or she was
probably trying to rob him,
I don't know.
So when I would get up and go to school,
I would fix their food, I would
pack my sister's diaper bag
and send them next door,
but the next door neighbor
wasn't hearing that.
I pretty much grew up around
a whole bunch of cats.
Father got out of prison, came got me,
brought me to California, Los Angeles,
with his side of the family.
Needless to say, same
events, I was a black sheep,
I was always in trouble,
I was ditching school,
I didn't listen, I had a C
average, my cousin was A average.
She went to the magnet
school and I was worthless
because, that's just
not what I wanted to do.
He went back to prison,
so I was stuck with my
grandma and my auntie,
and then I hadn't seen my mom for years.
I didn't see my mom again
until I was about maybe 14
and I tried to talk to her
about her situation with me and her,
and she told me that I was lying.
Mind you, at six years old I got raped,
three times.
The first time I told my mother
she called me a lying
bitch and slapped me.
So as a result, I never said anything else
and it happened two more times.
At the age of 14, I got raped
and then at the age of 16,
I got raped by three men,
back to back for seven days,
held at gunpoint in Detroit,
they kidnapped me from Inglewood
and they knocked me out
and I woke up in a car bouncing,
I had peed on myself and everything
and the next thing I
know I was in Detroit.
I had my jaw broken, I been
stabbed with an ice pick,
I've been robbed, I've
been held at gunpoint,
I've been slammed up against a brick wall,
I've been in a car accident
where I almost broke my spine,
I left home when I was 16, I've
been down here on Skid Row,
I done gotten to it with other men,
I done got cut down here,
I have bruises all over me,
I have a big burn mark on my leg
for where a man tried to set me on fire.
I mean, I don't know, I
just been through a lot.
I've been though a lot.
My daddy died when I was 17,
which in turn means in all actuality,
I have four years with him
out of my whole entire life.
- [Interviewer] So you were
on your own since when?
- All through it, didn't have nobody.
- [Interviewer] No, but--
- His mother died 2000.
He died 2001 and my
mother's mother died 2002.
- [Interviewer] So about when you were 16,
you were on your own?
- Yep
- [Interviewer] And what
were you doing then?
- I was prostituting,
I was robbing people,
I was in and out of jails, I
was in and out of institutions,
I was just running rapid,
because it was like, I was on
my own, I had nowhere to go,
I didn't know what to do and I was young.
- [Interviewer] And drugs
were part of the picture too?
- They became a part of the
picture when I got down here,
maybe a year and a half, I was almost 18.
I was drinking first,
no I was smoking weed
and then I was drinking and
then graduated to crack.
- [Interviewer] And
you're still using today?
- I still drink.
- [Interviewer] You drink.
And do you have kids?
- I have two kids,
which are with their dad
because of my lifestyle,
I was incapable of taking care of kids,
because I was too busy in the
streets, being a street woman.
- [Interviewer] Did you
feel like you're following
in your mom's footsteps?
- A little bit, but I think I was worse.
I think I had a lot of
resentments against her,
for telling me I was
lying, for beating on me,
then I had resentments against my dad,
for in and out of prison and then dying
and leaving me lonely.
So I feel neglected, lonely, abandoned,
I'm just, I'm everywhere so...
- [Interviewer] Do you think
you have a victim mentality?
- I used to.
Now, I think I've took
the role of kind of victimizing people.
I'm very
angry,
where I fight a lot,
like you don't have to say
much and I'll hit you first.
I just,
anything makes me snap, I
don't like people behind me,
I just, I'm not a people person,
I'm not, cause I don't trust nobody.
- [Interviewer] Where
are you living today?
- In a tent.
- [Interviewer] On a street right?
- Mhm
- [Interviewer] Do you still
have contact with your kids?
- I haven't talked to my
daughter in about a year,
my son, in about two years.
- [Interviewer] What's
the hardest thing of all
your life here on the streets?
- [Amisha] The hardest thing in my life,
not being around my kids,
feeling like I'm the worst mother ever
and feeling low self-esteem
and low self-worth because I
feel like nobody values me,
so I don't even know how to value myself.
- [Interviewer] Nobody seemed to value you
when you were a kid,
so where would you have earned it from?
- [Amisha] Exactly.
- [Interviewer] Do you have friends?
- [Amisha] I don't believe in friends.
- [Interviewer] You ever been in love?
- [Amisha] No.
- [Interviewer] Do you
feel like anybody loved you
as a child?
- [Amisha] My dad.
- [Interviewer] Your dad did?
- [Amisha] By him being taken so early,
I don't know, now I don't feel like it.
- [Interviewer] What's been
the hardest thing for you
to go through?
- [Amisha] (sighs) Just being by myself
and wishing my dad was here to help me.
Thank you.
- [Interviewer] Do you
think maybe you're addicted
to this life, street life?
- Honestly, I hate this, but
I don't know how to get out.
- [Interviewer] Do you have
a record that would keep you
from getting work and all that?
- I've been to jail
for sales, DUIs,
so I have a record.
- [Interviewer] So it's not
just the drug addiction,
it's also--
- Buying and selling.
- [Interviewer] Yeah.
How'd you first get introduced to crack?
- My, not my first so-called,
but my second when he...
Actually, I went through a program,
for when I started drinking
and I met him in the program
and he was doing crack and
I was just an alcoholic
so when we did our six
months, we left together
and then we got into it and he was smoking
and that's how it happened, it just...
- [Interviewer] But today
alcohol is your big,
- Yeah
- [Interviewer] Your main go-to
- That's my first,
I won't leave alcohol Fernandez,
that's like my best friend right now.
- [Interviewer] And how do
you, how bad is your alcohol?
- When I wake up, I shake.
- [Interviewer] So your
first thing you do is you start drinking?
- Mhm.
- [Interviewer] What's your drink?
- I drink anything that says liquor.
- [Interviewer] Do you feel like,
the rapes that you went through as a kid,
were the most pivotal
thing that happened to you,
as a child?
I mean that your mom was in and out,
dad was in and out.
- That
was actually the most traumatic
thing as being six year old,
besides my mama beating
me, like I was adult,
because I felt like she hated me,
and I just went with it,
I knew her to hate me
and I never got any answers so...
- [Interviewer] How'd your siblings do?
- Well, somebody called and
said my mom was doing heroin,
because she used to hang
with the lady next door
and I can't say if she was or she wasn't,
but it didn't seem like she was,
so my sister went with her dad's mom
and my brother went with my mama's mom
and then I went with my dad.
So we all kind of like got separated
and then my brother went to a group home
and my sister don't even know who I am,
but I know her because I
used to change her diapers.
- [Interviewer] Do you feel betrayed
by everybody you grew up with?
- No, not betrayed.
Just like I was a mistake of being here,
because it seemed like everybody hates me,
that I try to consider loving.
- [Interviewer] What's been your darkest,
what's been your roughest point?
- The roughest point in my life?
The day my dad died.
It was the summer I graduated high school,
I graduated July 21st
and he died August 7th.
- [Interviewer] Do you
even feel like you deserve
a better life?
I mean, seeing as he never,
- I don't know.
- [Interviewer] you were never shown
that you deserve anything?
- I don't know.
- [Interviewer] How far
did you go in school?
- I graduated 12th grade
and then I tried
cosmetology, culinary arts
and child development
but I never could finish,
because I was too used
to drinking and smoking
and I just felt like
school was just taking...
So I just dropped out, I stopped.
- [Interviewer] Do you feel
like you'll be down here
the rest of your life?
- Sometimes.
- [Interviewer] You've been
down here your whole life,
right?
- Just about, I'm 37.
- [Interviewer] What do you
think would help you the most?
- Right now?
Somebody that actually loves
me enough to really help me,
understand me, sometimes
just listen to me,
I just, I don't know.
Biggest thing that I
want that would help me,
especially spiritually is just somebody
that loves me the same
way that I love them
and I can't show trust or love to nobody,
because I never get any
so I stay bottled up
and I stay angry.
I don't want to be angry,
but down here you have to,
'cause they take advantage
of you, they beat on you,
they rape you, they drug
you with all kinds of stuff.
- [Interviewer] When
you were a little girl,
did you have dreams of doing
something with your life?
- I've always wanted
to own my own daycare,
because I love kids.
- [Interviewer] What do you feel like
is the most important lesson
you've learned in your life?
You've been through so much.
- [Amisha] That God doesn't
put more on me than I can bear,
'cause I'm still here.
- [Interviewer] All right Amisha,
I'm gonna give you something
to make your weekend a little easier.
Hopefully you don't spend
it on alcohol.(chuckles)
- [Amisha] I already have
the alcohol.(giggles)
Thank you.
- [Interviewer] Thank you.
- [Amisha] Felt good to let
somebody (indistinct) (giggles).
- [Interviewer] Felt good to talk?
- [Amisha] Yeah.